hey I'm Dane DeHaan and I'm doing the
last thing on my phone for Wired last
Google search was how do I do that
I googled snapchat name cuz I didn't
know when you give people your snapchat
name if you're supposed to put the
little at sign or not I called my wife
at lunch to see how she was doing and
okay and two hearts to my wife American
flag the poop the landing airplane and
taking off airplane hearts
pretty much every color of heart got
coloring book by chance the rapper my
last photo was at our panel for valerian
we took a selfie with everyone at Hall H
[Music]
maybe seamless it's big in New York
especially New York Times crossword
puzzle app I've been playing SimCity
sometimes it's my dog Frannie she is 9
or 10 years old and she grew up on the
streets of Compton